le président ukrainien
volodimir zelensky qui s'est exprimée
discours que l'homme vous avez pu suivre
en direct sur france 24 le président
ukrainien
gauthier rybinski je me tourne vers vous
qui appelle les ukrainiens à prendre les
armes
oui sous la forme la plus classique
c'est à dire celle qui convient quand on
est dans un cas celui désespérée c'est
la peuple au peuple en l'appellent
pardon au peuple en armes puisque la
recommandation la hap elle-même du du
président hélène ci consiste à rameuter
non seulement les réservistes mais
également toute personne qui aurait de
près ou de loin des connaissances dans
le domaine militaire ou dans le
maniement des armes donc si vous voulez
ça prouve aussi la le caractère
impérieux est impératif de la chose pour
vladimir zelensky c'est que cette armée
ukrainienne quels que soient les progrès
qu'elle est qu'elle ait fait depuis 2000
14 depuis l'annexion de la crimée depuis
la création de ces deux républiques
satellites de moscou dont le nom de
basse ou là elle avait été il y avait eu
même des désertions de la part de
certains soldats ukrainien elle a fait
des progrès c'est clair mais elle n'est
pas armée la hauteur du tout à la
hauteur de dudu d'une armada qui est
l'une des plus puissantes au monde et
dans ce contexte si vous dans cette
configuration il s'agit au fond
d'établir un rapport de force qui soit
la réponse du faible au fort qu'on
connaît bien dans d'autres conflits dans
le monde de 10 de faire en sorte que si
le fort continuent d'attaquer ils
subissent quand même des pertes
substantielles au point que hélas est
intéressant au point que s'il y avait
des morts de soldats russes il y en aura
cela suscite une réaction est un réflexe
au fond d'eux de survie de la part des
russes qui eux mêmes devraient c'est ce
que dit vladimir de vaud le dow jones
qui dit l'heure de descendre dans la rue
c'est une adresse aux russes c'est
important parce que c'est cette adresse
qui est
fraternelle entre deux peuples qui ceux
qui se considèrent comme très proche et
c'est une adresse directement au peuple
russe est à dire quelque chose qui passe
par dessus poutine c'est lors dit de
dire ah ah ah bah oui non on ne veut pas
de cette cache en fait tout à fait avec
justement la menace qui pèse sur les
soldats russes c'est à dire que ça ne
soit pas une opération comme on disait
autrefois propres une des frappes
chirurgicales qui ne faisait aucune
victime donc là il il en riant parle de
manière très claire d'ailleurs il s'est
exprimé en russe à la fin de son voilà
de son discours et la conversion en
ukrainien puis il a fini en russe pour
s'adresser à ces russes et puis on
russophone égal à la traîne au
russophone d'ukraine justement lesquels
sont parfois écartelé parce que tous les
reçus au fon du crâne y compris dans le
dôme masse n'ont pas souhaité une
annexion de leur région par la russie
ils ont été parfois comment dirais-je
attiré par une forme de pattes duplicité
mais de double appartenance
appartenance à la russie parce que la
russie fournit et propose par exemple
des retraites bien meilleure et puis
appartenant soit les crèmes pour avoir
un commerce avec l'occident mais tous
loin de là n'était pas sur cette
longueur d'onde qui consistait à
finalement à ceux à se coucher devant
les desiderata de vladimir poutine il
est 10 heures 36 ici à paris jour